in with a story we've been following the
past month this morning a metro officer
shot in the line of duty began his long
road to recovery officer shane me
colonna's was released from UMC early
this morning he is now at a rehab
facility our Bianca Holman shows us the
first step in his lifetime of recovery
we were here at University Medical
Center four and a half weeks ago
the morning after Officer Shaima Colonus
was shot in the head and that day his
condition was described as grave and
most didn't think he would make it that
night was really hard for me nakia
Jackson Hale who works for Metro
remembers the moment she heard the news
officer Michael onus was shot near
Circus Circus
this was after a black lives matter
protests on the strip June 1st the man
accused of shooting him was arrested
staff at UMC have been caring for
Michael onus who has been on the force
for four years the mechonis family says
the 29 year old officer is paralyzed
from the neck down and is unable to
speak this is not going to be a cheap
venture this is the most expensive
injury rehab there is so we appreciate
everyone's support that they that you
have given us a number of fundraisers
were held for what is expected to be a
lifetime of expensive care as a Mickle
onus family embarks on a journey of
recovery first responders were by their
side a motorcade all for officer Shea to
an out-of-state rehab facility I think
in light of everything that's been going
on I think it was very important I think
it was really special and
the city has a very unique way of coming
together when people need us to do that
most prayer circles parades an entire
valley has been touched by Officer
Shay's service and his story I think I
would just want them to know that they
are not alone we're always going to be
here to support them whatever they need
there's a local Facebook group called
prayers for Shaima Colonus they're
urging everyone to keep their porch
light on to show their support for him
reporting from UMC Bianca Holman eight
news now
thank you